eu imagino que muitos de vocês aqui
nessa sala em algum momento das suas
vidas sobretudo na infância
imagino que muitos de vocês se quiseram
perguntas aparentemente todas
aparentemente sem respostas perguntas do
tipo o que é o vento como é a terra até
roca tem tudo tem fim
o trovão porque ele tem esse barulho
mesmo tempo tão belo e tão terrível
fizeram perguntas provavelmente do tipo
do ponto de vista do cosmos do espaço
será que nós estamos sentados de pé ou
de cabeça pra baixo
imagine que cada um de vocês encontrou
ao longo das suas vidas respostas para
algumas dessas perguntas na família na
escola nas leituras
agora vocês imaginem uma criança que
nunca enxergou fazendo essas perguntas
essa criança era eu eu nasci cega com
mais seis irmãos cegos e nos meus 45
anos eu era uma menina muito curiosa
eu só tinha minhas mãos e minha cabeça
em um punhado de perguntas como é que
chove como é que faz sol e as nuvens de
efeito a terra
será que a terra é oca
será que eu estou de cabeça para baixo
ea terra gira em nos meus 45 anos o meu
cérebro me deu uma teoria para todas
essas perguntas
eu imaginei uma montanha muito a
tá imaginei eu escalando essa montanha
eu até posso me lembrar dos detalhes as
rugosidades os pedregulhos as plantinhas
no sopé da montanha pois eu subi essa
montanha e ir lá no alto
eu encontrava o céu mas o meu cel
ele estava cheio de gavetas
eu até brinquei eu eu chamei a minha
teoria de teoria das gavetas da teoria
da relatividade existe a teoria das
cordas então a minha era a teoria das
gavetas
eu cresci estudei me formei jornalista
depois mestre em ciências sociais fez
doutorado em comunicação e guardei essa
minha lembrança da infância com um
tesouro um pequeno tesouro e ao longo
dessa minha vida de crescimento
eu descobri três coisas sobre a minha
teoria
a primeira delas é que a minha teoria
das gavetas estava estrondosamente
equivocada um céu civil
a segunda coisa que eu descobri foi que
o nosso cérebro
ele nunca nos vai deixar na mão ele
sempre vai nos dar uma resposta
uma explicação ea terceira coisa que é o
descobrir aqui por mais que a minha
teoria fosse uma teoria muito
cumprimentar e equivocada
na verdade ela ensaiava os primeiros
passos para a minha a
em função da minha visão de mundo e
então eu com seu consegui extrair de
tudo isso
a ideia central dessa minha comunicação
hoje eu descobri que a cegueira é uma
forma de divisão mas a diesel explorar
essa idéia eu eu queria fazer um
exercício com vocês dizer assim imaginem
se é o quando pequena e verso levado
essa minha teoria das gavetas para a
escola e dissesse para os meus
coleguinhas e pra minha professora o meu
céu tem gavetas
eu abri a gaveta de chuva chove a droga
vinha de inventar evento
eu seria ridicularizado provavelmente
diria o que sempre aconteceu ao longo do
desenvolvimento da cultura humana
quando uma pessoa por portar por ter uma
deficiência era desconsiderada
ao longo da cultura uma pessoa cega
sempre foi colocada à margem sentar ela
aí no canto não pode se machucar ela não
pode viver não pode dançar não pode
namorar sentar ela aí então ao longo da
cultura
a grande luta das pessoas com
deficiência das pessoas cegas não é para
serem pensados como super-heróis ou para
serem pensados com uma coisa mais inútil
do mundo né a grande luta dessas pessoas
é para serem consideradas como pessoas
serem colocadas no centro dos projetos
colaborativos
mas eu queria então pensar com vocês
sobre essa
a idéia da cegueira como uma forma de
divisão e volto a repetir não é uma
visão mágica adivinhatórias super
poderosa não é uma visão concreta real
nos meus 45 anos eu estava esboçando um
modo tátil de compreender o mundo e aí
para que a gente pense um pouco sobre
essa questão
eu faço a pergunta o que é ver e assim
mas já comprovou isso ver em primeira
instância é trabalho do cérebro
o cérebro está apto a ver seja ele de
uma pessoa cega seja ele de uma pessoa
não cega
o olho é o instrumento do trabalho do
cérebro porém uma pessoa cega se o olho
não é funcional o cérebro reinventa
percursos reinventa caminhos então a
ciência já comprovou quando uma pessoa
cega está lendo em braile e aliás nós
somos os únicos habitantes do planeta
que podemos tocar nas palavras e disse
pra os sentidos
a ciência já comprovou que quando uma
pessoa cega está lendo em braille é o
seu córtex visual que é ativado
então o que se supunha
ela não pode ver essa parte do cérebro
atrofiou 'não não não' três vezes não o
cérebro refaz o percurso porque o
cérebro é a máquina mais engenhosa que a
evolução criou o cérebro é plástico o
cérebro é reciclável sustentável o o
bico
tanto que quando eu digo que está na
cegueira é também uma forma de enxergar
nesse pacote também trará uma série de
outros adjetivos alegria felicidade
paixão beleza estética tudo mais então a
seguir não é esse poço escuro não é o
fim da linha não é um labirinto é um
estar no mundo feliz contente e às vezes
cristian angustiado ela está no mundo
com a centralidade do humano ea cegueira
junto tudo bem tudo num pacote que é bom
que pode ser produtivo que pode ser útil
para o pro para para um projecto
solidário de humanidade
a segunda coisa a segunda idéia que eu
queria estar aí da ideia da cegueira
como uma forma de visão é que essa visão
ela é tátil ela é sonora ela é o alfa
ativa ela é um mix de sensações
então a ciência também
ia pro cm própria na minha pele na minha
corporalidade de dentro da cegueira
significa ver com o corpo todo com as
mãos com as plantas dos pés uns ombros
com toda a pele com as costas ninguém
pode ver o que está atrás de si mas eu
posso
como toda essa corporalidade mas o bom
disso tudo é que não é só uma pessoa
cega que tem toda essa potência todo ser
humano tem essa potência entretanto
sentido da visão que é um sentido
externo e de lobby lisa quase tudo o que
faz a distância ou ou na proximidade
sentido da visão comanda tudo e de certo
modo e inibe os outros sentidos mas
todas as pessoas se quiserem podem ver
enxergando e podem ver entre aspas como
um cego todas as pessoas se quiserem
podem sim experimentar a visão da
cegueira
então vejo as tecnologias hoje avançaram
muito uma pessoa cega pode fazer muitas
das coisas que antes estavam interditas
a ela ela pode ir a fotografia pode ler
cédulas de dinheiro pode fazer operações
bancárias pode ler livros digitais que
ela comprou numa loja e pagou com seu
cartão de crédito
a seguir está muito minimizada
as limitações porém a grande luta das
pessoas cegas ainda é para serem
pensadas no centro dos projetos para
serem pensadas como cérebros válidos
capaz
de colaborar e de produzir porque vejam
a prisão ocular
ela pode ser individual mais ver vê em
toda sua amplitude e amplitude é
trabalho coletivo é trabalho de
solidariedade social um dos maiores
dilemas da humanidade hoje não é a crise
econômica não é a fragilidade das
democracias
um dos grandes dilemas da humanidade
hoje é o descarte dos cérebros a dengue
crise da humanidade é desvalorização dos
cérebros e cada vez que uma instituição
um grupo de pessoas um coletivo uma
pulga governante qualquer diz
não você não pode sentar ali no canto
que você não pode está se descolasse
ficando um cérebro está se
desvalorizando uma possibilidade de
colaboração
então a tecnologia minimizou a cegueira'
mas a grade luta ainda é simbólica ainda
é para que essas pessoas estejam no
centro de um projeto coletivo de
solidariedade e de cidadania
eu brinco e pediu o microfone porque eu
digo que sou uma agulha de bússola
desorientada tão micro microfone me
ajuda a ficar no centro pensando mas
muitas vezes na minha casa eu me posto
diante de um espelho e ficou ali
e o meu cérebro me entrega um punhado de
perguntas quem está olhando de ódio está
olhando de que posição
quem é essa pessoa no fundo do espelho
oposta mim como é que ela está essa
careta sorria fique séria eo meu cérebro
diz assim os seus espelhos estão dentro
você não precisa desse espelho de fora
os seus espelhos estão dentro e ali são
terríveis
eles são terríveis mas não um espelho só
seu que diz todos os dias você é
completa você é humana então com o tal
que anteriormente eu não nasci assim
para a catástrofe
eu não nasci para a tragédia eu nasci
para a construção é tudo isso pra vocês
eu já disse isso de diversas maneiras
é como se eu tivesse revisitado tempo da
minha infância como cio de 9 tivesse
reencontrado o meu céu cheio de gavetas
eu vim aqui com a minha mão com as
minhas mãos com a minha bengala eu vim
aqui com a minha cegueira toda branca
toda limpa para dizer essas coisas a
vocês eu não sei o que vão fazer com
isso não sei
espere mim tem enxergar como os cegos
consuma corporalidade inventa em outras
palavras porque a minha cegueira se
chama alegria à minha cegueira se chama
construção ea minha cegueira se chama
humanidade livre
não sei eu não sei o que vocês vão fazer
com isso
mas foi muito bom falar obrigado